nobody likes being trash-talked but it's
especially unpleasant when you and your
trash-talker are both high-profile
celebrities add in that we're
essentially talking about workplace
disputes between directors and actors
and it becomes a multi-layered personal
and professional attack here are some
directors who publicly disk their actors
JJ Abrams on Daisy Ridley it was a shock
when Daisy Ridley who starred as ray and
Star Wars The Force awakens told glamour
UK that JJ Abrams called her out on her
first day of shooting criticizing her
performance as wooden in front of cast
and crew as for why Abrams may have been
a little tactless with his criticism it
could be the enormous responsibility of
Disney's four billion dollar investment
in this franchise reboot resting on his
shoulders Kevin Smith on Bruce Willis no
other director has gone out of his way
to trash an actor like Kevin Smith did
with Bruce Willis Smith's taking the
podcasts live stage shows and Twitter to
call out Willis Smith's beef in this
while filming cop-out Willis couldn't
have cared less and went out of his way
to make the production difficult for
everyone on Marc Maron WTF podcast Smith
said the experience was quote
soul-crushing Michael Bay on Megan Fox
Michael Bay didn't turn on Megan Fox
until after she compared him to Hitler
in a magazine interview after that Bay
was free to not only fire and replace
Fox for the third Transformers movie but
to tell GQ quote I'm sorry Megan I'm
sorry I made you work 12 hours movies
are not always warm and fuzzy they
eventually reconciled with Fox starring
as April O'Neil and Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles in 2014 which Bay produced Paul
Schrader on Lindsay Lohan Paul Schrader
took a chance cast in the troubled
Lindsay Lohan in the canyons a
low-budget erotic thriller at every
opportunity
Lohan held up production with insane
demands and erratic behavior
she clashed with co-star James Dean and
even forced Schrader to strip naked in
front of the crew because she had to do
the same thing for a love scene in the
end Schrader wouldn't admit to regret
over her casting but he did throw a jab
over whether he did cast her in
something else amusing quote it doesn't
involve a co-star she'd be perfect for
it Stephen Norrington on Sean Connery
the League of Extraordinary Gentlemen
was such a difficult production that
ended the careers of both its director
and its star Connery endlessly told the
press what an idiot he thought
Norrington was never acted again and
Norrington bound to never direct another
film and this was only his fourth movie
following a massive success of his work
on the original blade Vincent Gallo on
Christina Ricci after their time working
together on the 1998 road movie bufflove
66 director and star Vincent Gallo
called co-star Christina Ricci
ungrateful and accused her of being an
alcoholic or that quote she was on cough
syrup the whole time more than 15 years
later Ricci responded when asked about
Buffalo 66 on HuffPost live but a nice
but must that movie trapped in a car
with a raving lunatic thanks for
watching subscribe to our YouTube
channel to watch more videos like the
one you just saw and leave us a comment
to let us know which Feud you think is
the nastiest
[Music]